Hello, everyone. It's September 29,
2023. We're here in the Active Inference
Institute's quarterly roundtable number
three. So this is our third of the
quarterly updates.
We have guests. I'm Daniel, one of
the officers of the institute. And I'm
Blue Knight, also another officer of the
institute. All right,
we are a participatory online institute
that is communicating, learning, and
practicing applied active inference.
You can find us active Inference
institute or the address. We'll be
moving things over more to the institute
address, though. We're inference active
on Twitter or X, and here's more
information. This is recorded in an
archived Livestream, so please provide
us with feedback so we can improve on
all aspects of our work. All backgrounds
and perspectives are welcome, and we'll
follow video etiquette for live streams.
So today, in this quarterly update, we
will first cover some big developments
and updates at the Institute and
Ecosystem Scale, then go over
some educational and research updates
from our Edioactive and Reinference
organizational units, respectively, and
then have some fun and entertaining
musings on where we're going for the
last months of 2023. Where we can all go
in 2024. And if you're watching live,
please feel free to add any questions in
the live chat and then in the last
section, we'll be able to scan over that
and look at your questions.
All right, first, updates from the
institute at the organizational scale.
One of the big highlights of the
last months and really of the year and
of really all of our work together was
the accomplishment of this collaborative
paper that we released in August of this
year, the Active Inference Institute and
Active Inference Ecosystem. We had a
great team of co authors and to give a
visual abstract and just a teaser
for those who might want to learn more
about this paper. We went through a
great collaborative process to document
and align on various aspects of what had
been, was, and will be happening.
And on the right side is figure one.
This is an overview of the institute's
structure itself in engagement with the
ecosystem. On the left side are
a representation of our open source
products and some of the functions that
they provide in the ecosystem. There's a
lot more to say, but Blue, what do you
want to comment on or what was it like
for you? It was
super intense. I think that we applied
for a phase two grant, which I think we
should talk about maybe. And in doing
that phase two Pose grant, this was the
preparation that they kind of give you
in the phase one. And it really is about
becoming like a big business or a
big corporation or a big organization
right. And what it takes to really get
organized and anchor and manage a large
community of people, which I think that
was really good for us.
I don't know how much managing we do.
We're a very distributed system, but we
do already oversee or engage with a
large community of people. And what does
that look like when maybe we have
conflicting factions or things get
dropped, like the ball gets dropped in
one court or another. So I think that
that really kind of brought to light a
lot of the things we need to work on and
also the things that we're doing a good
job at. Awesome. Yeah. We'll come to the
grant in a few slides, but just to
verbally describe the image. On the
right, we have the circle,
a golden ring that alludes to the COVID
of the Par Pazulo and Friston 2022
textbook. And that ring symbolizes the
active inference ecosystem and also the
boundary between the Institute as an
entity and the ecosystem as niche in the
Institute itself. Starting on the top of
within the ring, we have several
official bodies or organs. We have the
Board of Directors, who select officers,
as well as scientific advisory Board,
which is an informal guidance and
insight group, which we'll come to
later. And the Institute provides
institute level functionality and
support for the two organizational
units, which are Eduactive, which is
focused on educational outcomes, and
Reinforce, which is focused on research
work. The organizational units host
through facilitation, other processes,
different projects that are all sorts of
within, on and out there in the
ecosystem, and then out in the
ecosystem, we have all different types
of activities and products and
organizations and players. And if
you're listening to this, we encourage
you to get involved. If it's something
that you want to learn more about, then
the paper is a great place to start,
best starting place that we've made so
far. And the next step is to take that
active step and actually get involved.
Anything else to say on this? We should
probably highlight the fact that our
research unit, which hasn't been
formally we've formally renamed our
research unit to Reinforce, which we
haven't announced yet. So I think as we
are talking about the Reinference Unit,
we did that kind of in the construction
of this paper. And because we've been
educated and researched, and we just
decided that Reinforce was more fun,
kind of shouting out to active inference
the whole thing, not just the active
part. Fun. Yeah. So thanks again to
all the authors here and also people who
contributed their insights and just
didn't want to be co authors. All right,
carrying on with institute level
updates, on August 22 of this year,
we had a really amazing applied active
inference Symposium. This was our third
such symposium. The first was in 2021,
with Karl Friston as a kind of one
person symposium last year. In the
second symposium, we highlighted
robotics and a variety of theoretical
applied work in robotics. This year,
we built off of the December 2022
framing of Friston et al. Designing
ecosystems of shared intelligence, and
we wanted to put it into play. And so we
co organized with a really great team
enacting ecosystems of shared
intelligence. And here are the
presenters and discussants who joined
and enacted the symposium.
And there's two intervals. It was an
awesome symposium, super exciting to
hear the breadth and the depth of the
work happening in the ecosystem. So for
here, all I'll say is check out the
program and recordings and transcripts
if you want to learn more about that.
It was an epic symposium, though, and
thanks again to the co organizer team.
Anything you want to add? Blue okay,
as Blue alluded to earlier,
we applied for a phase two
grant within the NSF program, Pathways
to Enable Open Source Ecosystems. So
here's just two visualizations that are
provided by the NSF to describe a little
bit of what they mean by an open source
ecosystem. On the right side, there's an
open source product, and then through
a pathway to sustainability, an open
source ecosystem can exist, which
includes here not just scientist, open
source product and external user, but
governance documents, scientists
onboarding support, external users, the
product developer, community,
distributed defect, management,
development and integration, and
security. And it was super fun to think
about our work in this broader sense of
open source products. Open source
doesn't only refer to code. So thinking
about what does a really rich,
multimodal open source product look like
and what is it? And you
want to add anything there, blue or I
can add more. Yeah.
So the paper that we wrote was kind of
the scoping document for the grant, and
it's what the people do in phase one.
And in terms of open source, I think we
have done everything open source at the
Institute, like all of the things that
we've done from the beginning of our
formulation until now. So it was kind of
good to have that acknowledged that you
can have an ecosystem around education
or around just
live stream videos or information
sharing, information management. We've
really built up the active inference
community. I think we've been a value
add because somebody has to kind of
organize and give meaning to kind of the
random contributions or not random, but
I think it's helpful in a
field that's so new and that moves so
quickly in terms of research
developments and everything else.
Yeah. Thanks. Just to give a little more
detail, the primary submitter on this
grant was the University of Washington
Applied Physics Lab via Copi Scott
David at the IRS IRI, as well as
Blue and I. And as Blue mentioned,
it was really fun to see
who was ready for what. Who wanted to
throw a value into the arena, who wanted
to put a comment on a Google doc, who is
ready to state their hourly rate
and scope of work and get involved. If
there's pragmatic value of that kind on
the line? Who's ready to work
in the meanwhile? And so it was just
many discussions and negotiations,
and as we can smile
and laugh at now. A lot of curveballs
and things happening. So it was great
times. Okay, moving on.
Just within the last weeks, we have
submitted our form 1023 to the
IRS. And so we soon expect and prefer
ourselves to be a 501 tax exempt
organization, which means that donations
that people provide to us, of which we
have received none so far, will be tax
exempt. Once that status and
all associated infrastructure is ready,
we'll begin philanthropic campaigning
with Blue especially. We are working on
policies and procedures proactively so
that we can have compliant ants ahead of
time and just stay right and relevant.
It would be extremely helpful and much
appreciated if anybody was interested in
contributing their experience, networks
or resources to what it could
be for a philanthropy or fundraising
program at the Institute. We're open
to how that might develop.
And so if you see a high leverage
opportunity for what you know or who you
know or however, then some
truly amazing things could happen. And
if you know, you know, and if you know,
then help. Anything you want to add on
this? I do want to add that
it was really interesting in developing
ecosystem infrastructure in the Pose
grant and in the ecosystem paper. It was
really interesting to see what it takes
to be a sustainable ecosystem, to really
evaluate that at the level of the
Institute and the ecosystem. And I do
think that what makes organization
dissolve. It's like time and people
and money. It's like time and money,
time and money. As long as people have
time and people have money and interest
level. So we have a great interest
level. As we'll talk about, I think in
the coming few slides we'll demonstrate
that, but how do we get people to keep
having time to commit to the Institute
and the organization? So I think that
one of the key things that we need to do
is fundraise philanthropy also,
but also grant writing. So these two
things will be, I think, central to
keeping the Institute, like being the
glue that keeps the Institute together
in the coming years. So I just want to
just highlight that for anybody who
wants to come be some glue, come provide
some adhesion in the niche, that'd be
great. Yeah, it kind of goes without
saying, but it's easy to skip.
Everything that has happened so far has
been a purely volunteer effort,
including this very little, little
Livestream. And the last
few months have signaled and anticipated
and readied for literally the first
paid people to do anything for the
Institute, which is a big game changer
and would scaffold our time. And so that
will be quite a transition point.
Let's continue also at the Institute
level, we continue with our volunteer
program. As always, I can do nothing but
encourage and exhort you to volunteer
and get involved at the Institute.
Being a volunteer supports your
engagement with projects and learning
groups, whichever ones you're
interested, it gives you repeatedly
affordances provided to get involved
with active inference and your
contributions will matter. The questions
you ask on a live stream will be
published by the active inference
journal. The questions that you write in
the textbook group coda, those do become
part of a shared knowledge, niche,
code, developments that you provide
something that makes it more accessible
or applicable, those are huge in the
setting that we are and will be in. So
please volunteer and encourage other
people who could be looking for
technical or philosophical education,
community mentorship, all these
different things. This is a great way.
And for those who would like a little
bit more structured of an approach to
getting involved, we continue to have
the internship program. There's about 20
active interns from around the world who
are engaging with different research and
education affordances, and we are up to
now five successfully completed
internships. So to those who completed,
it's been honor and an epic time.
There's so much more I could say. But
it's really exciting what interns come
in with, because we,
ourselves, or from what we hear, people
are excited to apply active inference
and to improve their own education and
understanding of what active inference
is and how they might use it or grasp or
handle it. And then to have
this lightweight internship program
that makes a connection between
the Institute and the person, gives a
container and a name and a timeline and
an asynchronous document for people's
engagement, whether they're in a
traditional educational program like
an undergraduate student or a graduate
student or probably the majority
of which are outside of a traditional
educational program and just lifelong
learners and lifelong cool people, and
they just come to work
and hone what they do. So it continues
to be very inspiring and I encourage
people to be interns.
And also for those who would like to
facilitate or mentor, we would
like to start that discussion about how
that might work. Anything else
you want to add? The active
inference matchmaking service.
There's so many funny ways to take that,
but yeah, what do you expect and prefer?
I meant like matching mentors and
interns. Yeah, that's it, of course.
And then just a little summary update.
Across our different platforms
and public interfaces,
we see continued growth and activity.
Just one plot. This is
our channel, YouTube channel. Growth
through time. Just kind of interesting.
Slow and steady wins the race. But it's
also always good to see that first and
potentially second and third order
derivatives increasing.
Anything else you want to add? No,
I think the YouTube channel has really
blown up in the last quarter and I think
a lot of that we just have to shout out
to the Chris Fields course because the
views are astronomical in those videos.
It's really blowing up. So thanks Chris,
if you're watching. And to everybody
who's viewing those videos, and taking
those courses, which it's truly.
Actually yeah, yeah, we'll return to
that, but good point. And also for
people who are interested in even social
media management, video production,
podcast editing, discord moderation and
governance, meta governance, there's a
lot of things that don't require some
technical fluidity with the active
inference kernel. So there's a lot of
ways that people can help. So don't let
it provide too much friction or freeze
you out if you feel like you want to be
involved, but you wonder if you don't
know enough about some technical area or
philosophical framing, it's totally not
required. And there's a million ways
that we can work with wherever people
are. And actually,
that's like one of the key areas that
we've identified in our ecosystem
oversight is social media management.
So it's not all about
the math. So many people come to us
like, I'm so curious, except I can't do
math and it's okay. Actually, can you do
Twitter? Because really there's a lot
of opportunities for involvement with
the Institute that aren't math heavy.
Before we head into the organizational
units, here's the big picture on which
activities are happening. This website,
which you'll find heartily linked from
basically anywhere, you are always
summarizes the up to date representation
of what activities are happening and
what you can do to get involved. So I'll
just go over this and we'll talk about a
few of these projects in the coming
slides. So in the space of publishing
different medias, we have the Live
Stream project where we organize and
prepare for different live streams.
Following live streams, transcripts are
created and published through the Active
Inference journal, which through the
work of Alex, Holly, Dave Others is
always improving. And it's an exciting
time for all of these natural language
processing analyses as well. This is all
being pushed to the GitHub that allows
you to clone off the current state of
the art in all the transcripts and
translations. In the learning groups
area we have the Pardol textbook group
Cohorts Four and Five continuing through
the textbook group Fundamentals of
Active Inference, Sanjeev Namjoshi's
book in progress and two courses which
we'll come to later, physics is
Information Processing by Chris Fields
and Constructing Cultural Landscapes
active Inference for the Social Sciences
by Avel et al. In the software Space
and Activity, we continue on active
Blockfrence, where we work from both
ends to make cognitive modeling more
accessible and applicable. We work from
the technical capacity side to develop
the active Blockfrence project itself as
a package utilizing CAD CAD to apply
active generative models. And we also
work from the system or domain of
interest side, working with people
wherever they're at in their analytical
or programming abilities and just
starting to get the inklings of the
recipe for generative modeling.
Together Robotics and Embodied, JF
continues to develop his work with Lego
robots and societies of mind. Active
inference ontology also continues
maintaining and slightly improving as
well as extending the active inference
ontology. And we have two weekly
discussion sessions, one more on the
educational theme, one more on the
research theme, but ultimately they're
both just how it goes in the moment.
Anything to add?
All right. In Eduactive,
our educational organizational unit,
one of the most exciting continued
activities is the active inference
textbook group. Cohort three, just
within the last weeks, finished their
journey. So congrats to those who stuck
it through cohort three. Cohort four is
now in chapter six recipe for generative
modeling, continuing on with the book.
And cohort five is starting off there in
chapter one. Everyone's welcome to join
either or both of these cohorts, which
are staggered so that you can attend
the same time zone and get sampling
across the book, or you can stay on one
trail at a time and switch time zones.
Everything's recorded, everything is
collaborative. In our shared workspace,
it's always possible to register and get
involved. All backgrounds are totally
welcome and encouraged. So if you've
seen this textbook and or
you want to learn more about what the
only active inference textbook in the
play right now says,
and also connect a ton of dots and bring
in a ton of other resources and more
then the active inference textbook group
is a great place and you'll meet many
people who are also interested in
similar topics. Anything else?
Blue it's fine.
Okay. The course that began in May 2023
is now about five six completed. That's
physics's. Information Processing by
Chris Fields. It's been a journey and
can't wait for the fifth discussion
section, which is tomorrow, and then the
6th lecture and discussion and that
will have locked in the completion
of the first course at the institute.
We'll be able to publish the proceedings
of the lectures and discussions as well
as the asynchronous question and answer,
which Chris Fields is very graciously
answering. Then we'll be able to explore
cohort or individual based learning
structures around this really
first principles and groundbreaking
content that Chris is sharing. Want to
add anything on this one?
Just wow. That's all. Yeah.
Also in the courses space. We continue
on with the constructing cultural
landscapes. Active inference for the
social sciences course with Avel,
Ben, Mahault, Lorena and myself. So Ben
Mahault, myself and Lorena have
completed their sections with a
lecture and a discussion, although I
guess Mao's discussion is coming up.
We look forward to also the continued
activity in this course as we remarked
on in our last quarterly roundtable.
Second one this year has
and will see us go from zero courses
to two completed courses. So both the
physics and the social sciences,
which under some understandings run
the gamut of multiscale systems. To have
both of those at such high
quality volunteered
and catalyzed by real
unique expertise and also broad
and diverse participation is
incredible. Anything you want to add?
Blue just that as we are
starting to have courses hosted by the
Institute and completed. Anybody
interested in having a course hosted by
us should reach out. And anyone familiar
with or interested in accreditation is
also something like we've been thinking
about what
would certification in active inference
look like, what are the key build up
skills? And how could we develop a
program to say someone is certified in
active inference? It's something that
we've been thinking about at the
Institute scale. So if you have ideas,
we would love to hear about them. And if
you have experience, we would love to
get your input. Yeah, it's not
covered in this roundtable, but the
qualification certification, something
that we're thinking about and the
pedagogy and developing and hosting
courses, these are all things that we
will work on in the education
space of live streams. We continue to
have exciting and unique live streams
here's, just kind of a slice of life
here's. The upcoming live streams for
the coming 30 days. We have the
roundtable that we're in right now,
strangely looping. We have Chris
Fields's discussion tomorrow, we have
Social sciences discussion next week,
lecture six and discussion six for
physics, active inference for the social
sciences, Avel's lecture and discussion
and a guest stream on conviction,
narrative theory and a new
live stream paper based series kicking
off on message passing. So it's kind of
like a flavor of sometimes the
work to prepare for this live stream is
just to coordinate with a guest and it
doesn't require any kind of expertise in
their topic, actually just a curiosity
in it. Other times we are
operationally or logistically supporting
the course teachers and also just
showing up. And then there's also work
like the zero preparation where for
weeks to months ahead of the live
stream, we're studying through a paper
and leveraging the questions
that we have by asking early
and asking often and precisely or at
least legibly that enables the questions
that are asked before the live stream by
the zero preparers to then actually
realize the addressing of those
questions. Instead of a thousand
scattered notebooks after the fact, or
there being no fact and just 1000
scattered notebooks. The dot zero I'm
very passionate about because it is a
way to do the homework early
and by doing so, change how things
actually happen. So if you're interested
in having any kind of
impact or learning with the live stream
organizing and preparation process,
whether you have this or that
familiarity with the video and the media
and the communication side or with any
topics in and of themselves, it's super
fun to invite people and have
broad invitations,
curations and facilitations. There's a
lot of exciting things that people can
get involved with, so please do. And
other than that, it's been a true
highlight of the quarter and the year to
have all these live streams.
And as mentioned earlier, following each
live stream we go on to publish the
proceedings and publish them on GitHub,
where they're all versioned and
collaboratively edited and also publish
them to Zenodo to get the DOI and the
URL briefly
from re Inference, we continue work
on the active inference ontology active
blockfriends robotics and embodied.
And we have several of the Institute
seed projects related to graphical
interfaces for active inference and
cognitive agent modeling. And then
there's the plethora of individual
projects that people are working on on
their own. Anything you want to add on
any of those projects? No, thank you.
Okay, well,
as we head into the last months of our
activity in 2023 and plan
to have a quiet December. So really only
two more months of activity this year,
and then we'll be in next year. So, as
usual, while scrambling to prepare for
the presentation and trying to convey
what we could and should, I developed
this small meme. So here
on the bottom is the timeline, quote
timeline. We're here in September,
2023. Soon it will
be classical New Year's, and we'll be in
2024. So here's us thinking,
wow, 2024 should be
really exciting, but also we remember
feeling that way in 2022 and feeling
that way in 2021. But this entire
concept is a nested thought from the
future. What do you think about
that blue? Or what are you excited about
in the past, present or future?
We don't get a treasure map. Right? So
that's not something that comes with the
Institute. So it's always, I think,
exciting to think about what the future
holds and looking back, how we've
come so far and the leaps and what has
caused exponential growth and all those
things. I mean, it's always just
exciting, right? So some future thought
maybe we'll be thinking about how we did
make those big transitions every year,
and we kept making them, and kept making
them, and kept making them.
Cool. Yeah.
One more specific call
to action other than the earlier
communications to actual or plausible
participants, volunteers, interns. We'd
like to really make a special call for
those who are interested in joining the
scientific advisory board or
recommending or introducing somebody who
you think could be helpful on the SAB.
SAB is an informal body. We have
office hours with them and shared
documents with them. It's very opt in
and flexible. Other SAB members,
like Chris Fields went on to do the
course, and just recently, Sarah Hamburg
started facilitating the Morphstream
series. So it's a way to get more
involved and have even more structured
contribution or differently structured
contribution. And it would be amazing
to have the SAB participants
as liaisons and advocates and
co learners and co creators in
the coming year. Because we select the
SAB on a yearly scale, it would be
great. It's always open to apply.
However, again, in the coming several
weeks, if we could reach
out to people who might
have a positive synergistic relationship
with being on the SAB, it would be very
special and appreciated. For us.
Well, that's it for this short
roundtable, so let's just give
any thoughts. Meanwhile, I will
wait for anyone in the live chat who
might have questions. If they write them
in the next few minutes, then we can
address them or just talk about them.
But other than that, what's on your
mind, Blue, or what are you excited for?
Um I don't know. I'm excited for
what's going to come up in 2024, I think
will be a big year for us. I'm excited
to see if we get funded or don't get
funded, but I think, regardless, we've
learned a lot about where we are and
where we're going. We've gained a lot of
certainty about our existence in the
niche and about our niche also, which is
great. At any time that you reduce
uncertainty, you're able to, I think,
help validate or solidify your existence
as an organization or a human or
whatever in the active inference way.
So I'm excited to kind of see how that
plays out in our future.
Unfolding. What about you?
Yeah, that reminds me of the bookstream
series that you facilitated with Tyler
and on Bijean Kesri's work about
kind of using active inference to
highlight the organizational generative
model nested generative models. And
rather than talking about uncertainty
being out there in terms of the aspects
that are not known about what's out
there, it's kind of like a glass half
full, glass half empty, starting with
the certainties and uncertainties of the
generative model as enacted through
policy selection. And so even
from the very most informal beginnings,
like the strange loop and the excitement
was around applying active inference to
and by and with and for active inference
in the multiscale setting and through
the bookstream, but also through a
million other vectors,
2023 has come through hugely
on that and yet
it remains a fledgling and
nascent volunteer work as
well. So it's epic.
Do you have any last thoughts? Or we can
conclude.
We can conclude, I think. All right.
Thank you, Blue. Thank you, everyone.
Hope this was a useful roundtable and
see you next time.
Okay, nice. All right,
we will see you later. Maybe tomorrow,
maybe if I can make it, I'm going to
try. To the discussion. To the yeah,
to the discussion.